c'est extra deux voire trois jolis
sourires comme ça ça me fait très
plaisir de vous accueillir
alors bonjour au dos qui viennent de
nous rejoindre et qui sont avec nous et
qu'on a vu dans le générique tout à
l'heure bonjour à mélissa yasmine qui
sont là bonjour les filles bienvenus on
peut se tutoyer tous les trois pour les
quatre mêmes tous les 5 tout le monde
parce qu'ils peuvent intervenir aussi
fabien et stéphanie vous êtes en
quelques classes toutes les trois un
train même classe oui quel collège ont
connu ce nom c'est sa croix jusqu'à
présent à besançon c'est ça oui ok il ya
des copains des copines qui vont vous
regardez forcément alors qu'ils vont
commenter qui vont dire elle était ce si
elles étaient ceux là donc vous avez
offert un joli sourire pour nous parler
de quoi les filles de
l'hypersexualisation ouais les pires
sexualisation ça représente quoi pour
toi la semaine c'est le fait de donner
un caractère quelque chose qui n'en a
pas à la bad
ouais
quelles sont les raisons à ton avis de
l'hypersexualisation je voulais en
parler
enfin on voulait en parler parce que
c'est d'actualité
on le voit souvent sur les réseaux ou
dans les médias etc
je combats puis ça touche tout le monde
surtout en lice à vous ça vous parle
aussi stéphanie l'hypersexualisation
maître fabien kovac et je pense qu'on a
perdu un certain nombre de repères dans
notre société aujourd'hui c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
donc il ya un petit peu à un brouillage
des frontières csii a semé ouais un
brouillage des frontières entre le le
monde enfants et nous ni femme et mis
d'accord toi t'es quoi tout était une
femme tout court
bah bah j'espère tu va le devenir en
tout cas j'en suis sûr j'en suis sûr
l'hypersexualisation c'est aussi un
phénomène c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire mélissa oui comme les
les enfants présents par l'école
primaire et il portait un cartable
ensuite il parle des sacs à main la
manière donc sa vie très sexy l'éthique
aussi
ouais le cosmic les maquillages sont
moitié tous les 3 non non d'accord alors
vous à maquiller un peu peau pour la
bonne cause un voilà parce que c'est
vrai qu'en télé il faut toujours un tout
petit peu de poudre
il ya l'attitude aussi une attitude peut
être très sexuel si parfois dès la fin
de l'école primaire
vous l'avez senti vous parce que vous
êtes au collège vous êtes des grands
maintenant je pense plus au lycée quand
même ouais ouais donc le lycée c'est
pour bientôt là est ce que vous êtes en
troisième tout le monde passe au lycée
l'aller 3 1 mais c'est super déjà
félicitations on a peut-être un rôle
mais aussi les médias tiens puisque tu
es envie de me parler yasmine à
l'hypersexualisation oui donc les médias
projette se noient les médias c'est donc
la télé la radio la presse écrite et les
projets qui ne rien dire mais l'image
inouïe une image de femme parfaite que
un enfant voie et pense mais considère
ce que tu penses on enfants qui y voit
une femme à la télé enfin habillée d'une
façon assez provocante provoquant dirons
nous voilà bah pour lui c'est un peu bah
oui c'est la marque motel de famille oui
c'est vrai campus et les réseaux sociaux
qui diffuse l'image d'une femme qui
n'existe que pour sa beauté bien il y en
a certaines qui sont surfaits des
spécialités jeu personnes habiles à par
exemple n'est ce pas voilà on pense pas
son cerveau canton personnes à bil'in
pense à sa plastique plutôt un bon allez
on va s'intéresser aux parents parce que
ils ont un rôle dans tout ça le rôle des
parents et l'entourage
inès pour toi par rapport à
l'hypersexualisation est déjà faut
savoir que les enfants ils prennent
enfin c'est comme ils sont eux au
quotidien avec les parents c'est sûr
qu'ils prennent exemple en premier donc
c'est eux qui sont responsables de leur
éducation
enfin c'est eux qui nous tourner ni les
parents c'est de la faute de tout va
bien
de mimétisme aujourd'hui l'enfant veut
ressembler à l'adulte et ça c'est
vraiment très compliqué et d'ailleurs il
ya une dizaine d'années on parlait des
mini-miss aux états unis mais finalement
on a le problème aujourd'hui en france
de la même manière et je crois que c'est
pas forcément l'enfant qui veut
ressembler à l'adulte c'est l'adulte qui
veut que l'enfant ressemble à l'adulte
oui parfois l'adulte reste dans le monde
de l'enfance et n'apparaissait pas envie
d'avancer encore autre chose tu va
rajouter quelque chose après ea plus il
ya deux types de parents il ya ceux qui
qui il se soucie pas trop ils disent que
c'est un effet pour le micro c'est un
effet de mode et que c'est tout à fait
normal que leur enfant sait pas c'est
pas forcément un problème à régler enfin
et après il ya ce en fait ça peut ça
dépend à près de la vie du débat rang
parce que il ya des parents par exemple
qui sont une enfance enfin c'est juste
un exemple mais qu'ils ont eu une
enfance où ils pouvaient pas faire ce
qu'ils voulaient donc ils essayent de
faire le show sur l'enfant est alors
qu'il a pas forcément envie l'enfant et
comme les concours de mini-miss grâce à
un exemplaire à ce qu'on dit mais bon
tout cas merci à toutes les trois défis
de nous avoir apporté un petit peu de
notre moulin sur les paires
sexualisation je sais pas si vous avez
une solution quelques secondes vous avez
une peut-être ou plusieurs mots faciles
pollution oui petite solution non
peut-être déjà au niveau des médias
ouais donc c'est nous qui sommes la
faute de tout mais après ça départ les
médias france 3 je pense pas que c'est
c'est le principal acteur moi si je peux
me permettre de vous donner un conseil
alors je dis les jeunes c'est très peu
c'est très prétentieux de dire ça mais
c'est pour me toussaint je crois que
faire très attention parce que vous êtes
une génération écran c'est à dire que
voilà vous êtes né avec les écrans en
stéphanie vous savez ça va bien le papa
aussi connaissent a donc il faut prendre
un petit peu de recul et c'est vrai que
c'est à nous parents ou grands-parents
de dire il faut faire très attention
prenez un peu de recul ne prenait pas
pour argent comptant ce que vous voyez
où ce que vous entendez ou ce que vous
lisez aussi un
donc voilà ça c'est tous les médias